and the following graph is y a function
of x so in order for y to be a function
of x for any x that you input into the
function any x for which the function is
is defined so let's say we have y is
equal to f of x so we have our little
function machine it should spit out
exactly one value of
y if it splits out multiple values of y
we don't know what f of x is going to be
equal to could be equal to any of those
possible values for y so let's see if
this for this graph whether for a given
x it spits out exactly one y
well the function seems to be only
defined so the domain of this function
is x is equal to negative 2. that's the
only place where we have a definition
for it and if we try to input if we try
to input negative 2
into this little
this little black box what do we get do
we get exactly one thing
no we put a negative 2 here we could get
anything negative 2 the point negative 2
9 is on is is on this relation negative
2 8 is on this relation negative 2 7
negative 2 7.5 negative 2
3.14159 they're all on these so if you
put a negative two into this relation
you actually get you actually get
essentially you actually get an infinite
set of values it could be nine it could
be three point one four it could be
eight it could be negative eight you get
an infinite number of results so since
you it does not map to exactly one
output of this function the following
graph what in the following graph y is
not a function of x